[Applause]
Brad Pitt is one proud papa Brad and his
ex Angelina Jolie's daughter Shiloh
turned 14 on Wednesday now a source
tells ET despite her parents split
Shiloh is close to both her mom and dad
brad is so proud of Shiloh and who she
has become
he loves that she always stays true to
herself and is so good to her brothers
and sisters we want to make it a family
affair
of course those brothers and sisters are
Maddox Vivian Knox pax and Zahara all of
whom Brad shares with his ex you and
your children are your best friends it's
a nice life Brad and Angie split in 2016
in April 2019 a ruled that their
marriage was officially dunzo now a
source tells ET that you have come so
far and are getting along so much better
since the custody rules have been worked
out Brad's kids are the most important
thing to him he tells his friends he
learned so much about life from his own
children no doubt Brad is a proud papa
and a Hollywood star for the ages
but guys he's become our quarantine King
good evening
I'm dr. Anthony foutch bringing the
laughs with his doctor pouch impression
on Saturday Night Live they have two
tests and the tests are beautiful I
don't know if I would describe the tests
as beautiful unless your idea of beauty
is having a cotton swab tickle your
brain and delivering the weather on John
Krasinski's web series some good news
Brad how's it looking out there
looks uh pretty good
yeah thanks Brad and let's just say it
like it is
quarantine it's looking good on Brad the
56 year old Oscar winner was spotted in
Malibu on Memorial Day rockin some long
locks that are giving us major legends
of the fall vibes
hey there's Justin oh you remember
Tristan it's a pleasure to meet you no
really the pleasure is all mine and I'm
drooling anyway like I was saying brad
was photographed rocking those Tristan
trusses 25 years after the film's
release along with some ripped jeans and
a gray tee under a green long-sleeved
shirt as he checked out his pal fleas
motorcycle he's like a fine wine he just
gets better with time it's really
exciting and last week he gave us a
glimpse at his new look in a special
video message for college grads in his
hometown of Springfield Missouri hi
everyone Brad here from quarantine with
a shout out to the graduating class
Missouri State University the
university's president shared the clip
on Twitter and it had us feeling feels
must be very strange doing this in these
trying times but no we're rooting for
you our money's on you to make this
world a better place
and we wish you all the best in your
future endeavors
so you did it you made it
enjoy Congrats again and think big
[Music]
you